j'ai eu la chance d'être sur scène à 5
ans au mariage à mon frère michel
et pour moi c'est là que ça a commencé
et et
j'avais mes frères mes soeurs qui
m'accompagnait peuvent ils
tous le mariage qui était leur tout le
monde qui était là les amis la famille
des étrangers des gens que je
connaissais pas j'avais 5 ans puis j'ai
commencé à chanter j'ai senti quelque
chose tu me files c'est sûr que ça m'a
vite et
qui pouvait croire cette petite fille de
cinq ans qui comme des milliers d'autres
dit un jour je serai chanteuse
février 1995 séance de travail pour
l'album que lui a entièrement écrit jean
jacques goldman nous assistions un peu
sans le savoir à la naissance d'un
succès
[Musique]
comment
je reviens souvent jusque là bien dans
le souffle c'est même la rythmique pas
et fait ses traits un peu sexy va
commencer
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre qui est céline
dion ne nous sommes rendus dans son pays
le québec
et ce n'est pas tout à fait un hasard si
on trouve dans cette immense province du
canada ainc l'actif du ciel dessiner une
carte de france
sirène gratte ciel à première vue
montréal à ses terres typiquement
américain r américain mes paroles
françaises sur toutes les plaques
d'immatriculation la devise du québec je
me souviens je me souviens de mes
racines françaises
[Musique]
depuis une semaine lors castres de
céline répète tout seul pour mettre en
place les nouvelles chansons en vue de
la tournée en europe
omniprésente lorsque sa fille a commencé
à 13 ans plus discrète maintenant voici
comme tout le monde l'appelle maman dion
[Musique]
c'est la première véritable séance de
répétition avec céline on ne se refait
pas maman dion est à l'affût aller coûte
[Musique]
waouh
[Applaudissements]
bah je sais pas
on a beau avoir derrière soi une
multinationale du disque il arrive
encore d'avoir besoin de sa maman pour
un conseil la fête a trouvé assez lent
où j'aimerais mieux que je répète une
couple de fois je sais pas encore c'est
comme quand je fais c'est beau
la vie sans toi je sais pas je sais pas
et se disent que je le répète souvent
est ce que cette percée loge tout moi je
trouve ça un show sera nécessaire comme
le statut assez lent oui mais moi je
fais pas de pouvoir par dessus avec
octobre toi tu peux voir avec les lakers
pourquoi vous arrivez à chanter son
accent que vous avez l'accent québécois
que vous parlez c'est une très bonne
question mais malheureusement je peux
même je n'arrive même pas à répondre à
cette question là on a une je sais pas
je comprends pas parce qu'il ya même des
gens au québec qui chante en québécois
c'est à dire qui chante
beaucoup de sport qui devaient y dormir
tranquille il chante comme ça et c'est
une scie du foc foc music
cccc champion québécois mais moi je
trouve je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
toujours changé toujours parlé avec mon
accent québécois mais quand on chante je
sais pas c'est normal c'est naturel j'ai
compris tous les maux je peux je serais
pas capable de chanter
chez moi j'ai compris jamais besoin de
ce parti fait rater je sais pas
malheureusement je pourrais pas de
répondre à ta question c'est naturel
voulu faire un triomphe parce que c'est
une énorme star déjà j'ai rarement
entendu une jeune fille de 7 à chanter
de cette manière céline dion
1984 la france découvre la voix d'une
jeune fille de 15 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
aujourd'hui
sa carrière a commencé trois ans plus
tôt avec l'envoi d'une cassette un agent
réputé au québec rené angélil la maman a
écrit les paroles l'un des frères la
musique c'est d'ailleurs lui qui à force
de téléphoner aux producteurs en
question va le convaincre d'écouter la
cassette deux heures plus tard la petite
fille de 12 ans est dans son bureau
je demandé de chanter et elle a dit oui
même si moi j'habite chanter
avec un micro et nous sommes à j imagine
toi tu es dans un terrain très
populaires au moyen qui s'appelle la
place des arts il va chez toi tu es la
place des arts devant 3000 personnes
puis je lui ai tendu mon stylo comme ça
je dis tiens fait comme c'est un micro
et alors là elle était toute gênée
n'avait pas beaucoup parlé et tout à
coup on s'est levé et s'est comme
transformée elle était sur la scène de
la place des arts et chanter devant 3000
personnes et moi ça m'a tellement touché
qu'à la fin je veux je pleurais - des
larmes c'est un moment exceptionnel
image pas ces images d'un passé
omniprésent dans la mémoire de céline
pendant leur temps libre au milieu de
leurs quatorze enfants papa prend
l'accordéon maman le violon à famille
nombreuse nombreux souvenirs je me
répète à chaque report
à chaque repas on prenait notre
fourchette notre couteau on était six
autour de la table
puis on tapait toujours du pied puis en
attendant que ma mère ne servent leur
poids ont frappé toujours notre
fourchette notre couteau une cuillère
après les putschs ketchup et de trêve
fait de relief une mayonnaise qui on
faisait toujours de la musée
du
vin on omettait divers avec de l'eau du
jus ou du coca ou je sais pas trop quoi
puis on avait le temps de terminer ok on
n'a pas eu notre lot le tarn et de
plomber
télé nature jusqu'à temps qu'on retrouve
la note dans les verres puis l'on
faisait de la musique longue des fous
los angeles californie capitale musicale
des états unis bien avant d'être célèbre
en france céline était déjà une star au
pays des stars 10 millions d'albums
vendus brienz lui compose une chanson
bill clinton invite à chanter lors de
son investiture disney fait appel à elle
pour la chanson titre de la belle et la
bête et quand aujourd'hui elle vient au
tonight show l'une des émissions
vedettes de nbc elle s'offre le luxe
très rare de chanter en français
[Applaudissements]
le cd est fraîche alban les eaux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poutine
à l'entendre aujourd'hui converser avec
l'animateur vedette on a du mal à croire
que céline ne parlait pas du tout
l'anglais avant d'avoir 17 ans durant
six mois à l'art et à sa carrière pour
apprendre la langue du pays qu'elle
voulait conquérir l'amérique
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi que je fais moi
trois mois de travail en studio à new
york aux bahamas et ici à los angeles
céline enregistre son quatrième disque
en anglais
toute l'année elle fait travailler sa
voix au moins 15 minutes par jour mais
pour un concert ou un enregistrement les
vocalises dure plus d'une heure un peu
comme un athlète de haut niveau qui
chauffe ses muscles avant une
compétition quand je fais sur scène
quand j'étais en studio j'oublie tout la
technique faut pas que je pense monde il
faut que je me tienne droite pour que je
fasse ça comme ça faut que ce soit au
nom et le show must go il faut que chan
faut que je pense émotions faut pas que
je pense technique du tout mais quand je
m'entraîne vocalement il faut que je
pense technique que je me tienne droite
je respire bien
il faut quelqu'un les notes son hôte
il faut pas que je suis comme ça faut
que je penche la tête ou que je tourne
comme ça si je fais une note haute et
que je tourne la tête je peux pas me
blesser la voix et quand je fais ça
c'est pas mon coup c'est mes doigts qui
font ça mais c'est comme une
superstition je moment donné je sais pas
je me sens très c'est dans les mains
j'ai lu mais qui deviennent glacé
énormément et je sais pas j'ai mon cou
chaud donc je sais pas j'ai c'est
peut-être une habitude que je prends de
faire ça comme ça mais c'est je vais pas
quitter mon pays du poppers sur les bacs
les flots
depuis quelques jours céline éprouvent
des difficultés avec sa voix alors elle
boit beaucoup d'eau chaude pour empêcher
l'inflammation et l'on ne sait où finit
la concentration ou comment son
inquiétude elle se rappelle peut-être ce
jour où elle a dû monter sur scène avec
un début d'extinction de voix
je suis allée ça assène j'ai fait ma
première chanson [ __ ] je je pensais
mourir
c'était tellement ça me faisait
tellement mal chanté le tout mon corps
vibre et parce que je faisais des
efforts de chanter la tension derrière
moi des musiciens qui me regardait piqué
qui voulait me donner leurs forces la
tique voulait me donner tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient l'a finalement bon je chante à
deuxième chanson ou en plein milieu de
la chanson est un solo de guitare alors
au son de guitare je suis sortie de
scène
j'avais tellement en deux mois le fil au
mans se déplace pour venir d'entendre
chanter ils payent pour venir entendre
chanter même pas capable de chanter
j'avais honte là j'ai commencé à pleurer
puis je me suis dit je peux pas leur
faire sauter et leurs aînés qui est mon
mari qui mon agent aussi est arrivé sur
scène
puis a pris le micro piezo au monde et
au besoin de vous expliquer vous vous
entendez técély n'est pas en forme et
tous ceux
et le monde les gens sont tellement
extraordinaire parce que lyon comme
c'était comme correcte avec eux au début
oui on sait pauvre titre c'est pas grave
qu'elles se reposer était a besoin de
repos à travers trop forte et ils m'ont
n'était pas franchie
à la suite de cet épisode
céline avait dû passer trois semaines au
repos total sans parler du tout réduite
à communiquer par écrit alors par
sécurité elles préfèrent se rendre chez
le docteur edward à cantor
laryngologiste à beverly hills sur les
murs de son cabinet les disques d'or de
platine de diamants offerts
personnellement par ses patients
je me suis occupé de pas mal de monde
d'elvis presley
aux beatles michael jackson et
puis pouvez voir la
whitney houston
pas mal de gens sont passés par ici
[Musique]
chez céline
immense plaisir que je vous offre un des
plus beaux dessins que j'effectue
seulement pour les eaux mais ce n'est
rien comparé aux belles chansons que
vous chantez depuis quelques années
derrière la boîte postale du fan club
céline dion se cache une maison de la
banlieue de montréal le club fête ses
dix années d'existence il a depuis
quatre ans pour présidente pauline la
soeur de céline qui travaille chez elle
bénévolement
5000 membres qui pour une centaine de
francs reçoivent une photo de magazine
parents et une carte de membre donnant
accès à quelques privilèges depuis le
succès de céline en europe le volume du
courrier a doublé une centaine de
lettres par jour poèmes proposition de
chansons demandes d'autographes
voire plus j'essaie de comprendre après
quatre ans et demi de de bénévolat dans
le fan shop de céline je me dis pourquoi
c'est quoi le but de ce2 de s'accrocher
un artiste comme ça pourquoi le but de
décrire un fan-club de rentrer membres
je pense que c'est curieux parce
curiosité possiblement ou par un manque
de
d'amour ou un manque de compréhension
envers les gens qui les entourent je ne
sais pas
dégage beaucoup en spectacle quand tu la
vois personne même les très chaleureuse
va te donner la main m mais sur ton
épaule elle comme ça
septembre 1994 la télé canadienne
retransmet en direct le mariage de
céline et rené ils avaient jusqu'à lors
tenus secrets leurs relations rené
l'agent de céline mais surtout il est de
25 ans son aîné sur cette différence
d'âge sur la réaction de son public
céline est d'une rare sincérité
moi c'était important pour moi ce que
les gens pensent de moi
je voulais pas les blesser je voulais
pas qu'ils en ont on se voyait avec un
prix charme un tournage on aurait voulu
que soient jeunes
c'est tellement pour ce qui est
important pour moi et puis je me suis
dit j'ai toujours été sincère avec les
gens
j'ai toujours été sur la même longueur
d'onde avec eux j'ai toujours tout
partagé avec
le plus beau moment mais la plus belle
chose de ma vie c'est rené parce que je
l'aimais pour moi je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que l'amour c'est est ce qu est
le plus important parce que ça fait que
je bâtis tout autour de ça alors si je
veux être franche avec les gens si je
vais être sincère
si je veux que notre relation dure
mais il faut que j'affronte ça puisse y
même s'ils veulent que je sois heureuse
ils vont accepter mon bonheur ils vont
accepter mon choix s'ils l'acceptent pas
c'est parce que notre amitié n'est pas
vrai
la californie donne à tous un faux air
de vacances qu'on ne s'y trompe pas la
tenue et estivale mais jean jacques
goldman est là pour travailler direction
le studio
ben ce qui se faisait c'est plutôt jean
new york
ou plutôt comment c'est dans un coin
usine c'est un coin dangereux tous les
studios sont toujours dans des coins
dangereux
ça lasse des quartiers pas très chaste
ah oui c'est vrai il ya des musiciens
je crois que c'est logique
[Musique]
nous park et les non dits
sur les murs comme des trophées les
photos des artistes qui ont enregistré
dans ce studio petit nom mais je
bien sûr que si j'avais du travail
conforte défatiguer tu peux prendre
derrière nous je te jeux sont fous
[Musique]
ça peut d'ailleurs parce que ma petite
vie si vous travaillez pas l'être tous
viennent bendit qu'est ce qu'il fout là
andy warhol
[Musique]
autre surprise ô combien plus importante
pour jean jacques goldman la version
anglaise de la chanson qu'il a écrite et
composée pour céline
[Musique]
première lecture pour que tu m'aimes
encore devient évident at what it ex
c'est ça que ça pince un
peu
[Musique]
c'est moins directe pour que tu m'aimes
encore que tu m'aimes encore là mais le
problème serait à payer ses impôts
[Musique]
elle m'échappe un peu quoique c'est plus
plus tellement l'amène jeu j'ai
découvert un peu le texte j'ai vu les
problèmes qui sont venus ce qui est
incroyable c'est que c'est une chanson
en français on nous on a tous un
problème pour deux pour faire sonner
des mots français par rapport à la
langue anglaise et là c'est le contraire
qui se passe faire cette chanson été
conçu en français et puis on trouve que
l'anglais sommes moins bien quoi mais
bon c'est peut-être aussi une première
impression
si ce n'était le silence de la cabine
d'enregistrement
on se croirait sur un ring avec un
boxeur juste avant son combat
you may line up
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une interprète hors du
commun quoi elle fait partie des des
cinq grandes quoi et je mets déjà dedans
aretha franklin
barbra streisand par exemple elle est
dans le lot quoi ensuite ça s'entend
je me faisais la réflexion tout à
l'heure ça fait quelque temps que je
n'ai pas entendu et elle mène des
intonations l on lui donne pas une
mélodie on lui donne une ligne mélodique
elle propose immédiatement 3 4 lignes
mélodiques différentes et des
intonations qui sont qu'à elle
[Musique]
c'est sans doute parce qu'il a autant
d'admiration pour céline que jean
jacques goldman se sent aussi concerné
par sa carrière par son image le clip de
la chanson je sais pas bien tout juste
d'être tournée céline en a écrit le
scénario
premier visionnage pour jean-jacques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
support à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à voir ces terres de petite fille céline
attache visiblement de l'importance à la
vie de jean jacques et il ne se prive
pas de rendre sa sentence
safa un côté un peu série b films
érotiques italien
[Musique]
on envoie quelques planches posées mais
j'ai un spécialiste des films érotiques
salah
[Musique]
sam ça
c'est pas sexy c'est à mon avis non
[Musique]
en ce jour de septembre à montréal
céline dion est en tournée en tournée
pour une grande cause la récolte de
fonds pour l'association de lutte contre
la fibrose kystique l'une de ses nièces
est morte à 16 ans de cette maladie
génétique jusqu'à présent incurable
depuis onze ans céline est la marraine
de l'association
grandes causes grands moyens elle visite
cinq restaurants de la chaîne dont elle
est propriétaire lenny classe
mais bien sûr pour beaucoup cette
journée est aussi l'occasion de
rencontrer pour de vrai la vedette
il y à tous ceux qui désirent des
autographes et ceux qui viennent avec
des cadeaux
la collection de michael jackson
récupérant les présents mais toujours en
éveil eric et comme on l'appelle en
québécois la bonne soeur de céline
autrement dit son garde du corps
le parcours du combattant commence
toujours par sa fait 3 heures que
j'attends il se poursuit par ne poussez
pas je ne peux plus respirer
et il se termine presque immanquablement
par mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait à ce
maudit appareil photo
céline ne le cache pas elle adore la
foule
et
c'est quoi le plus dur dans une journée
comme ça c'est céline rencontrer les
gens et tu veux plaire à tout le monde
essaie même de plaire à tout le monde
parce que c'est dans elle est très
généreuse et des faudrait pas quitté
mais un an plus tard à 60 km on a eu
notre stade
[Musique]
nous
l'étape suivante est toute particulière
car une partie de la famille attend
céline aux premières loges adhémar le
pape ap
c
enregistrement interview voyage céline
n'a pas vu les siens depuis trois mois
anouma beaucoup parce que
comment est ce qu'on voudrait comme
l'ipad à partir d'autres hommes
selon elle à prendre et les frères
cascio j'apprends casserait la place
qu'elle voudra à nous appelle d'asseoir
et 6,2 proche de la fin que j'entends
crier au bout de la ligne babel
et comme ennuis
[Applaudissements]
mais très vite céline est emporté par la
foule d'autographes en photo tout juste
le temps de glisser une caresse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si loin si proche
ah oui
oui
salem
et quand c'en est fini des admirateurs
c'est au tour des radios des télés
vous n'arrivez pas à la voir là votre
fine avec moi qu'il y a
[Rires]
céline et ses parents enfin réunis le
temps d'une photo devront attendre le
soir pour de véritables retrouvailles
dans l'intimité
mon amour pour cette ville à l'epo à
l'épeautre masse épaules c'est la même
amour que j'ai pour mesurer à 20 comme
j'ai pour pallier j'aime j'aime pas les
tout ça avec mon fils paul que je
travaille comme les plus vieux puits
tous âges et cela même un monde c'est la
même chose excepté que celina mois à
m'emmener dans des choses j'ai chialé au
japon avec thual et 25 fois en france
avec elle j'ai connu deux des choses
extraordinaires ces dames ont sorti de
ma cuisine c'est moi moi j'ai écrit dans
ma cuisine pour elle et à la mauvaise
sortie de ma cuisine oh là là vous pop
et robert bobin
merci de m'aider
[Rires]
nous étions partis pour faire le
portrait d'une chanteuse à succès
derrière cette image de star dans une
limousine aux vitres teintées nous avons
découvert une artiste d'une sincérité
désarmante émouvant aussi émouvante et
sincère comme cette chanson à l'histoire
si particulière vol dernier jour de
l'enregistrement de l'album français
jean jacques goldman propose à céline
une mélodie un texte dédié à karine sa
petite nièce disparue ça a été très dur
pour moi mais je n'étais pas contente
parce que moi je rêve voulu
exprimer de cette façon la chanson ce
que je ressens pour karine ma nièce mais
j'écris pour mes chansons et quand on
est père et bénit de quelque chose
peut-être qu'on sait de façon toujours
ça les mots viennent peut-être pas
nécessairement facilement
mais de voir une personne comme jean
jean gauvin qui m'écrit un texte si près
de moi après mes émotions si tellement
sensible
je te dis pas que c'est que je n'ai pas
hésité à vouloir l'enregistrer c'est sûr
que je voulais l'enregistrer
mais je me sens pris à plusieurs
reprises
cherves en studio
j'ai commencé à chanter la chanson plus
ça sorte d'impôt levé le groupe attend
dans la gorge c'est sortait pas du tout
plu j'ai pleuré les larmes que j'avais à
pleurer j'ai recommencé le je me suis
dit écouter les offres et hitchcock afin
de chanter j'ai trop d'émotions c'est
je veux la chanter avec l'émotion mais
avait de l'émotion
contrôle
je suis content mon possible
côté dans un restaurant de les super
ponza que j'ai changé
je me suis contrôlé je sais pas ce que
tu avais je mangeais survenu au studio
j'étais ok je suis prête à tout - deq
[Musique]